he separates actors who make a living
and acting versus those who call
themselves actors but work as a
bartender or waiter for years and never
cross through then there's a lot of guys
who are talented a lot more talented
than a lot of guys who make a living
they don't make a living because they
don't have the perseverance they don't
like the rejection you know they have a
look that maybe they look a little bit
too much like an actor who's working or
they might have a look that you know
looks good ten years ago or will look
good ten years from now there's a lot of
factors that go in to
- why is particular actors works why one
doesn't all those things have to be
how much do you think that versus luck
is just like any other profession right
preparedness maybe you make your own
blog right what about the actor of film
interviews more DIY what do you say to
that person someone that tries to go the
traditional route getting an agent
getting a manager where it's almost like
throwing darts at a dart trying the same
thing what do you say to someone that
has more of a DIY approach what did what
is the DIY is making your own films well
that's that's what you're good at then
your that's what you're gonna do a lot
everybody is good at making their own
movies are putting together their own
material
putting together a showcase yourself in
a theater or something that's that takes
a special kind of talent in itself and
people who are good at it do it guys who
aren't don't
director you kind of make your own way
with this or do you know I got a
production company
Ross studios I've always been proactive
you know I did a play and I convinced
the guy who wrote and directed to play
the filming of the movie and I helped
him raise the money to do it I've always
been a proactive I have not not really
wanted to sit and watch the phone away
from the phone right I like doing it I
like getting out there future
I read scripts all the time and try to
find good writers talented people I work
with producers that makes it fun